- Brendan, you got, you got
a six minute standing ovation
when 'The Whale' premiered
at the Venice Film Festival.
How did that feel?
I mean, you seemed so overwhelmed.
- Correct.
- Yeah. It had to be just so overwhelming
and that role was so important.
- I felt really affirmed,
surprised, astonished
and a little bit Italian.
- (laughing)
You're always welcome on this show.
(crowd cheering)
What, what, instead of asking him
because he was obviously experiencing,
what was it like to watch
'cause you've been shooting
this movie with him
and going through these
very intense scenes,
like you said you're like
always yelling at him
and you're, you know, very angry.
Like, what was it like
to watch that happen?
- I was a little nervous.
That was the first time we'd
showed it to an audience,
so I think we were all a little relieved
that they were clapping and standing and-
- [Kelly] Responded so.
- [Female Guest] And responded.
- Yeah.
Oh, that's intense.
I didn't realize it was the first time.
- Yeah, it's very nerve
wracking, but it turned out well.
- Oh God would never
want to experience that
in front, the first time
in front of ton of people.
That's brave.